apple cores are poisonous true or false
cut into an apple and you'll find some
hard dark seeds in the core and those
seeds contain a chemical called
amygdalin when it gets down into your
digestive system amygdalin can release
cyanide which is definitely poisonous
but normally when people eat apple cores
they just swallow the seeds whole the
shells on those seeds are hard so your
body can't break them down unless your
teeth or your kitchen tools do it first
in order to actually digest the
amygdalin in those seeds
you'd have to blend a bunch of apples
seeds and all into one very big smoothie
I mean a really big smoothie you'd have
to cram about 18 apples that's nearly a
hundred and fifty apple seeds into that
blender just to put a potentially lethal
amount of cyanide in your body so feel
free to eat all the apple cores you want
this food myth is false but maybe you
just spit out those seeds you know just
in case